do you think their method of retrieval
is just UPS dudes picking up sat tests
all over the ground it probably is yeah
that's probably the only thing they can
do or they have a dog sniff a Scantron
and they're just like go go find them
boy
[Music]
so what do you guys think about did you
guys take the SAT yes I think I did but
I just bubbled in anything so I could go
to sleep I took it I took it back when
it was still in the 1600s remember the
point system was like 1600 oh yeah yeah
and then it moved to like 2400. oh I
took it at 1600 too yeah I took it 24.
did it get harder yeah why'd it go up no
I think it's they split the cat I'm not
academic enough for this but they like
split uh the the point system so it was
like 800 for this 800 for that 800 for
that that's what it was versus uh I
don't know I don't [__] remember was
it stressful do you remember the prep
like how was all that [__] yeah it was
no actually I lie I [__] sucked ass
at it yeah I was stressed out but I
think it was also stressful because like
uh I went to like Sunny Hills which was
a good Academic School at the time for
high schools and then a bunch of Asians
and then I have older siblings so like
everything's always about like oh would
you get into scts you have to go to SCT
summer school if you're not picking up
your [__] which I'm like [__] falling
asleep in the St buck and drooling on it
and stuff but
um and I had smart cousins so it was
always just pressure your entire [__]
high school you're just like pressure to
make sure you do good on the SATs well
now imagine you take the SATs after
going through all that pressure
but a UPS truck bursts open and all
these tests get [__] littered out
some of them were recovered but 55
students essay SATs were never recovered
and they have to retail they need to do
an automatic Lake
score no they can make them take it
again you think some of them are like I
needed them all again
and this is the way and maybe nobody
[__] wants something
I wouldn't mind if they took my like
performance in school and just like and
AI created a score yeah that'd be way
cooler you know how stupid I was yeah so
how stupid
so stupid that I thought that test
taking was just luck and the way that I
would take tests is when it came out I'd
be like all right this time I'm gonna
get an A without studying and then I
would just start bubbling [__] and I
like process of elimination and hope
that I get a good grade and sometimes I
would get a c and when I looked back and
I was like this is how shitty the school
system is I shouldn't be able to guess
and still get a seat but it was only
like 10 of the time you got to see it
maybe right they're probably failures
now I did that exact thing so I don't
know if that ratio really calculated
relates to the best uh in Spanish class
I did the same thing because it was like
looking at Jiu Jitsu for me I was like I
don't know what the [__] this is but
everyone seems to like it a lot
oh no offense it's just like when I'm
looking at the sport I don't [__] get
it I see wiggling
you're not wrong there's a lot of
wiggling
so so for Spanish for me early in
Spanish I didn't know it was like
looking at like something I don't
understand so I was just guess see on
like every single one and I failed
Spanish
I guess yes yes yes see see he wrote
s-e-a-c-c C you're sorry s i oh okay
um so yeah the El Paso Independent
School District
um is currently working with the College
Board to determine a remedy for the
students whose tests were lost they have
to take it again they're just gonna make
him take it again yeah that's the
easiest solution that's the most school
thing you can do is just make them take
it again yeah you know in Japan during
test taking season they lock up all the
top floors because Kids jump off the
buildings oh [__] yep
so they take the test then they jump off
the thing they should at least do it
like wait you passed yeah mid-fall or
like when you get the scores oh oh okay
oh no that's rough dude it's pretty
rough huh damn their parents are intense
pressure dude yeah it'll be funny though
if like the top floor is really only
like one story though
I'm trying to make it less dark guys
acl's torn everywhere why do we have him
take the test on the top floor
why are they taking at the high dive we
hadn't taken the basement now we have
more students than ever what if you fail
your diving test
so I I guess apparently out there maybe
it's changing but like for the longest
time you only have one test that's
probably going to determine the rest of
your life so you take one test and
depending on how you score on this test
you go into like the major universities
right these major universities you
already have a career trajectory of
going into Sony or one of the major
corporations in Japan so like it's
almost as if like in the US you have a
lot of options you can go to the Ivy
Leagues you could go to the West Coast
ivy league equip equivalent you could do
all this [__] but over there there's
like a handful that are the top Ivy
Leagues there so then unless you're
wealthy where your parents can just send
you abroad and you go to like UCLA or
whatever if you're a normal middle class
kid that's going to determine whether
you stay like lower middle class or you
get to go up a little bit wow and
because the whole Court the structure
there is like you go to school like a
factory and after that you go into the
workforce like a factory you give your
life to one or two companies they don't
like it when you swap around they don't
see it as job experience they see it as
disloyalty so then you stick with us
right
and then you stay in there you move up
the ranks hopefully you reach middle
management and then you retire but
that's why there's that like stereotype
that Japanese got that whole like
discipline thing on lock you know what I
mean it's like they they go down one
discipline and they stay with that thing
until they [__] Master it that's kind
of kind of cool except for the whole
like suicide thing because you're
stressing yeah that's um so you have a
choice in junior high I think seventh
grade or eighth grade is the max you
have to do and after that you can go
into apprenticeship so you could be a
sushi chef you could do whatever so if
you're more like a like a blue collar
worker a lot of people go through that
way and they'll just be like I got I got
my education so now I'm gonna go into
like family business or something yeah
but like but seventh or 8th grade is
like 12 or 13 years old right yeah and
then from there you work at a sushi shop
or like let's say you want to be a hair
stylist or whatever and then you do that
for like every [__] day of your life
but like everybody just trusts that a 12
or 13 year old is like
um life knowledge enough to make their
decision their education is pretty good
so like okay so like think about it this
way you have kids running errands at
five years old already for the best TV
show by the way yeah so so so the first
couple of years uh they teach you chores
and and and how to navigate through the
neighborhood and normal life [__] did
they wash rocks they probably wash like
pebbles so that's that's the first
couple of years and then and then they
go into school by the eighth grade you
probably have a better education than
the US so wow that's not hard whoa what
the [__]
because we're like 30 something in the
world so getting rougher than that even
sounds a little too high yeah but they
don't they of course you're not
developing intellectuals by eighth grade
so by eighth grade you have regular math
skills basic skills and then from there
you go into any labor you want to do yep
yeah well we got a better birth rate
baby
that's why they're dying he's moving his
dick can you see it cam you know I feel
like uh the whole retake like yes like
Ryan said it's the most cool thing to do
just be like nah just retake it feels
like why not but it's also like 2022.
they might get let him off the hook well
it is 2022 and it's part of the problem
so
um some of the students were looking at
getting
um entries into these colleges and now
it's delayed yeah wait so like this kid
was looking oh that's [__] up Texas A
M and the deadline early deadline's
already shot so now they're hoping you
know they basically have one shot and
that's for the actual deadline to land
in January but they're not able to get
early yeah um notification on whether
they're going to colleges or not why
doesn't uh [__] UPS just pay for
scholarships
and uh UPS says this our employees are
working to recover as many tests as
possible and we will work with the
school to resolve this situation the
driver's actions in this case are not
representative of UPS protocols and
methods and we are addressing this with
him
because the door was left open on the
back we said the door was actually left
open
yes you think their method of retrieval
is just UPS dudes picking up sat tests
all over the ground it probably is yeah
that's probably the only thing they can
do or they have a dog sniff a Scantron
and they're just like go go find a boy
did you guys hear about how the all the
universities like enrollment is
dwindling like a [__] like crazy
yeah because people are waking up
realize it's a [__] scam yeah
dude bro especially we could be an
influencer yeah be an influencer dude
just go on Tick Tock we're only fans
like why dude College you're gonna have
a 50 000 debt for uh being a Social
Studies major
yeah like econ major or Communications
major like [__] off dude get my only
fans do some YouTube whatever the [__]
yeah dude what's gonna happen when
nobody has enough money to afford all
the different places you want to be on
only fans
oh think about that yeah you gotta
really pick and choose level six right
there dude because not everyone's on if
fans it's like oh
she prioritize my [__]
you have to narrow down to like five
different people yeah you're gonna have
to really economize yourself that's a
real pandemic once only fans is like
oversaturated it's like what do you what
are kids gonna do for work it's gonna
happen yeah what's gonna happen dude wow
I never thought of it inflation of only
fans users
too many there's too much Supply it's
too easy yeah titties are born every
[__] day that's true now they're all
reaching maturity two per person and
every year there's new 18 years
that's when our birth rate's gonna go
down because no one's horny anymore oh
yeah and then be like MILFs too much so
chicks aren't aging out
they're just they're actually aging into
exactly they're getting ripe yeah
yeah what are we gonna do what are we
gonna do and yeah guys like gills
basically and guys even like dead chicks
yep guys like everything that's like
dead ships you didn't like hey tell me
I'm wrong Anthony Lee it's true don't
[__] say my full name when you're
[__] talk I watched a 90-minute
Netflix documentary about how much guys
like dutches like necrophilia why so
long dead chicks now what do you mean
like it's necrophiliacs oh like dead
bodies yes what were you thinking well I
don't know historical figures like
Amelia Earhart
they never found our body by the way I
guess she's not confirmed I never found
her body so what are we gonna do as a
society
what are we gonna do
I that's what I'm concerned about you
everybody's trying to be well you know
what I don't blame them though because
only fans is a way out it's easy mode if
you're dude the kind of money that
they're making if I could sell money off
of my nipples I would it's life making
you know you might make like 3.50 a
month no but it's not enough dude what
does borderly say Bart's like I wish Geo
would [__] do only fans right he's
praying to the God praying because he
would do it he's a smart guy I know you
know we should pray for a Geo it's all
pray
I mean I'm in I'll do it with the boys
I'll do it with the boys
do what you want to do okay
oh come on
one of the guys you might be one of the
guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign